okay so wrote to the show oh yeah let's
go we are currently in the west coast of
kind of high school and so these guys
are in the locker room they're getting
ready for their final game in front of
you know and I'm you know prospect you
know get out MLB scouts so what we want
to do with you is you are known for
giving really awesome pep talks and like
get people fired up yeah so if you could
pretend that you are in this locker room
and you're going to fire up these high
school guys could you give me what what
what would you say you can looking right
into the camera and gives like our
desire to get wild you know I'm firing
up these high schoolers yeah is their
last chance to prove it to the MLB scalp
all right I'm gonna do the best i can
right here hey fellas you know it's your
last game right here there's a lot of
scouts out there you've worked a long
time to get to this moment and it's
pretty special I think you all need to
feel pretty good about just being here
being a part of this West Coast team
being able to play in front of these
Scouts it's a it's a wonderful
opportunity you have you have one of two
ways to look at this moment you can look
at it as all I have to like be my best
and I have to do this and you know try
to put a bunch of pressure on yourself
or you can go out there and allow all of
your hard work all of your dedication
all the moments that led up to this
moment take over and let your best self
show up I think the best mindset you can
have coming out here is just to leave it
all out there throw all your chips in
have as much fun as you can be as free
as you can with zero fear no worries
about whether you get out whether you
get a hit you can't control results from
this game and they'll mess you up but
you can't control your attitude your
hustle like you can control being a good
teammate let me go out there and you set
your mindset that no one's going to have
more inner fight than you at the end of
the day you're a walk away with your
head held high and I promise you the
scouts will like what they see because
on a daily basis and the major leagues
you get your butt kicked you get out a
lot but there's moments that you get up
there
you get the big head or there's a moment
when you keep pushing and you make a
play but it's how you handle the tough
times that really shows what you're made
of so don't forget that and I'm telling
you these Scouts they know what you can
do they know your strengths they know
what you've done in the past let it all
go go out there and just have fun play
with passion and I promise you can they
can see the invisible fight make sure
you're visible fight is bigger than
anything and you'll be okay let's go I
would I want to run through a block long
now let's go that was at it that was
beautiful hey unbelievable that I mean
the story goes you guys were down the
Giants were down to nothing and the AR
NLDS and you gave a prep speech and then
you guys went on to win the next three
games I can't take any credit for that
oh man no manage everything you do in
baseball this is the beauty of baseball
is you win as a team and you lose as a
team and even even if I happen to give a
speech it was because the leaders in a
lot of the veterans of the team who had
been there before yeah we're making
comments like if we don't say something
if we don't come together if we don't
make a change we're going home I don't
want you guys won that was unbelievable
because we had great players and great
performances how beautiful that was
beautiful I really want to go run
through a brick wall it's be honest
funny way let's do it let's play our
final gate let's go boys have some fun
his his name is Gregory gamespot we've
we've created him he is a right fielder
he bath right would you want to do this
would you want to have the honors and
plays him uh yeah the well why don't you
play you're the pro aren't you the pro
gamer you owe me a play all right I'll
play online come on let's go thank you
one by one run in three innings all
right you're right fielder oh there you
go you're up vagary gamespot take a look
at that stache that's a great set nice
little guys my stance all right so
square is going to be your power and
then circle is
good I a jar every circle can be contact
okay he's a power guy kind of like you I
actually modeled him off of your
existing player just you know oh ok
that's rating Gregory could swing it's
real good swing oh we got a little two
outs bottom first man on first oh looks
like I crushed it took keep going oh hey
hey + 12 spring training points earned
that's pretty cool so my players are
here we go now you're in the outfield
all you gotta do is run to where the
ball goes we don't know it might be
right might be left all right hey this
is kind of cool this is like really like
playing a game you get out and you got
to think about it yes let's think about
this Gregory who would you say was your
I don't know better body language what
are you doing why who stares out there
with their hands on their hips now
you're ready oh you were just we're all
gosh oh alright that's okay all right
now hold down the base you want to throw
to pedal really that's perfect hit the
cutoff man going on vintage a 98 speed
yeah does in high school come on no way
all right here we go at least your hands
get exercise come on buddy you would
never be caught out in right a talking
like that's right at least think it's
ready before what is it was gone I
didn't see what happened can we rub it
mmm you can head out our one but that
one is long gone so how about your
little champions eat Wheaties for
breakfast hundred fifty two champions
I'm up to bat we're down by no easy
again this kids killing it either great
marred easy goodies oh yeah got to be
kidding me they crushed it go ball oh I
got out again solid contact I got six
points for that one that's two on the
warning track warning track power man
doesn't push ups
hurry no no 32 two outs dude isn't to
win the game all right come on step your
game up this matters here we go what no
go to are you kidding me covering so are
you go pick off whoa thank you for
grabbing to charm well I don't lose my
hat that's got to be a double-edged onto
the wall man or you can be Gregor a
couple couple RBIs er well then just won
the game no big deal put us out I'll put
it up put a banger forget my head with
the video premiere oh hi are you running
how do you run I don't even own one so
for this one's just the left stick
you'll push it when you want to run but
watch cazeau go back get back go go go
go go look we're going to tell how many
out buddy i'm not paying attention there
you go ok ok Wow Gregory all right I've
ever had a lost it back about we were
bad it's gay men i gave up at top he's
not even hostile huh probably because of
my controller even learning the buttons
right now too this is super fun I think
you're doing a killer job for being the
first time playing wrote to the show
well we got another run somehow well I
could be gone I have no idea where r 1
to jump let's see it now good thing I
was out here in right field for that
yeah oh you know ok assuming haha here's
mark with another one it's get what we
got cans try to lose weight though ok
never loses did your awesome I'm not a
fad cool but I'll take it whoa it's four
to five nobody out come on move first
and third ok here we go Oh on the track
that mine are one get there go go oh he
laid out for it man you know what a
tussle a lot of hustle the scouts are
gonna receive this pitchers getting with
so now you came through you grew up in
arlington texas correct correct and you
were drafted for the first time by the
Brewers but then you
was to go back and then you were drafted
64th 64th by the Houston Astros what was
that like awesome it was a life-changing
moment it was it definitely was a dream
come true whatever i'm still playing
defense with nobody out maybe out
bases-loaded outro down one come on well
go I get it what will hold the show time
oh that's a little difficult that one's
difficult I'd puts me through the loop
to is bad do any Showtime moments where
time slows down let's learn about that
because you'll hold down our two and
then it'll prompt you for what what they
want you to do okay time to get some
runs 12 oh man probably based on that
right fielders not playing good defense
let's go for a base hit now so get up
the middle we will be drafted after this
game too so we'll be yep I think that
won't well timing out that'll be the
finale of the stream all right we lost
but all right I just go to the clubhouse
that was far no I actually I want I want
to that was really fun so it looks like
our high school coach has called us they
want to know where will you be when it
goes down will you be at home watching
line with your family you don't know
fishing begins our with my family let's
say will be with us ride pics seem like
a couple family guys I mean I was up
here we go I was at home watching it
online with my family ah this is the
dress this is that we have in a
projected spot I don't think so i could
i can tell you my actual draft i was
told that i was gonna go in the third
round ish and then went in the second
round it was like a huge shock and like
a big excitement sixty fourth overall
that's incredible we're cool well we're
letting need goes by let's have the word
around to let's see if i go in the
another question to all right second day
are we going gregory come on he had a
bad game
but you know all right so that guy at
the way Mary this is web slinger 67 @ XX
web slinger r XX who is the toughest
picture you have gone up again and it's
it's a great question i get asked this a
lot I don't it's tough to really say
like because throughout the different
years different pitchers are like on
different level right yeah you know when
I was really on Carlos Marmol was really
really nasty um Tim Lincecum whenever I
was with Astros he was and he won those
two sayang yeah he was uh he was one of
the nastiest ones I've ever faced don't
when he was doing 100 running and huge
curveball he turned me some split
changes that were like a left-handed
curve ball to the right side it was cool
and you guys became buds two ladybugs
either even before because we have to
say major you know like I'm always like
tim is amazing and his whole career was
awesome so those would be the two off
the top of my head you know Arrieta when
he wore the Scion was pretty nasty means
oh we got you still nasty
congratulations we were drafted by the
Brewers and oh hey guess what I was
drafted by oh this is wild well there
you go was this is this a setup this is
not set up I swear what number Tommy get
drafted oh sorry if it's 64 would be
really funny ma I wasn't paying
attention let's see if it tells me i'm
not sure to tell me huh here we go so
the GM of the brewers has contacted us
he wants us to come play how's that
sound do we say sounds great holy cow or
to be out around Rome did we get big
second second round what what pic ah I
want to say in the 20s I think I quickly
I looked at you and I looked back were
drafted you were hoping you're gonna be
drafted by your favorite team but this
is all good here the first one sounds
good its routes a very conservative wow
look at that stache terrific they're
happy we got us so do we say can't
believe it this is surreal he's very
play some ball
death pick you ever made or thank you
number two number two okay ready to play
some ball let's see they believe we have
talent we're counting on you working
hard for us welcome to the club and
should we thank them see we're going to
work hard this is unreal I'll work hard
can't wait to start love it love it Oh
be an accurate hollywood baby I will
spare the details behind a little bit
are you then Brewer sent you an offer
sheet I'm pretty pleased with where it
landed oh that's what are our advisor
told us he's pleased with it because you
can't turn down his offer so yeah let's
listen to it okay let's do it I've done
a lot of research and I'm confident that
the deal we're looking at is good value
for your draft position no I need to
hear thanks coach let's sign okay that's
all you need here perfect can you go
play college ball in this I believe you
can but that considers you in the east
west or central so same thing kind of
style okay but right now I know we're
being a 2nd rounder and you get if you
get a good deal on the second round
that's a big deal with it would you say
it was a tough decision the first time
you were drafting decided to go back and
try again to come here first time I was
Jeff it was like in like the 50th round
or something crazy there's a 40th round
yeah something like really late round
and they were and those times they had
draft and following and they really just
drafted me in case I went back to JUCO
to potentially draft the pole because i
thought i was going to be a big prospect
of next year which i end up going to UT
Arlington and so I just like two more
years and then I went from a 40th around
her to a 2nd rounder so that was cool
incredible we ever nervous that by
passing up that first chance that
something had happened down the road no
I I was thinking that I needed I needed
to grow a little bit i was real small
real skinny need to you know just a
little bit of development kind of like
me only i don't think i'm gonna grow
anymore I was tall I was really tall
skinny yeah tell like you but yeah yeah
right I know what we got our third
graders holding this interview
but I saw her I'm gonna have an adult
I'm gonna tell come on no no no I need
to see me standing and now I need to see
that all right so we'll we'll go into it
looks like we're in who we playing for
now we are playing for the farm team I
think double I biscuits I wanna know
that we're the shuckers ah man I want a
biscuit like t-shirt or something all
right we'll go ahead and do the final
gratifying biscuit we're coming to
butter you up ah my buddy David like
gloves that there's a team called the
biscuits the Montgomery biscuits in the
biloxi chakra homes 2488 at tre homes 11
is the winner and his question is what
is your proudest moment in your 10-year
career and how has baseball changed you
as a person that is an amazing question
I'm so excited to answer it by far my
proudest moment and my 10-year career
was probably the 2014 World Series I was
just that whole team and the it was a
tough year you know we had a tough
second half great first half tough
second half we were like the last seed
in the playoffs and we ended up winning
the World Series and it was just sharing
that moment with Morse and Hudson it was
crazy to see how excited they were so by
far that and as far as I it changing me
as a person its baseball has changed my
life in so many ways first of all I've
made a living and change my family's
life because of it to be able to you
know hopefully do some good in the world
through through my efforts of a baseball
field it's kind of like it teaches you
everything in life like leadership I
mean soul searching because it's tough
man you get beat up a lot and gallium
baseball and you just got to keep coming
back keep you know it's like a
persistent like non-stop positivity and
work because there's days you put
everything into it and you come home
with nothing he lost the game you didn't
have good at-bats and you just gotta you
just got to keep digging absolutely it's
changed it's changed my soul mate it's
time every
it shaped me I love the saying that like
you know diamonds are made from the most
intense pressure and major leagues
there's a lot of pressure a little less
pressure yeah crystal and even less
pressure you got cold so they fall and
the pressure that it's pat is hopefully
made me a diamond where did you learn
how to kind of put words like that so
eloquently eloquently I think grow well
that's just a quote that I've read i
just read so it's not necessarily that I
I didn't come up with that it's just
it's something that stuck with me you
know going through hard times like
because that's part of the process of
being a major leaguers I look for how
can I be the best you know like I love
playing the game I'm blessed to be here
how can I I got to do my physical work I
got to do my mental work I got to do my
nutritional work rest so just try to be
the best player I can shape you into a
good person you've gotta sharpen your
mind so I'm i read a lot of it I find a
lot of these things through study of
trying to be a better baseball player
sorry for messing with your diet was a
little sugary bubblegum you know what I
figured it was worth the risk to have a
good stream and it was pretty fun with
whatever farm you're headed in the right
direction in my opinion I agree
[Applause]